one of the things that I think so
interesting when I talk to combat vets
is the horror of war the you've seen and
and been around horrible things and yet
there's a warmth that combat vets have
to being in combat there's a there's a
they almost miss it didn't miss the hell
yeah but they miss something can you
talk about that do you have that yeah
definitely and because you tell this in
the story of intensity that that set you
on a path of destruction and yet you
have a warmth towards your time
downrange time can you talk about what
that warmth is with it with what you
miss a lot of veterans that I've talked
to you miss it because of the people
they served with it's knowing that I
love my guide to the left and right of
me or behind me in front of me and I'm
gonna do whatever I can to my and all of
my being to make sure he goes home to
his family why because he would do it
for me
you